este avión aterrizó en Brasilia con
Anderson Torres después fue detenido ex
ministro de Justicia del expresidente
Jair bolsonaro y en el momento del
intento del asalto a los tres poderes
secretario de seguridad de Brasilia es
sospechoso de convivencia con los
violentos y en su casa encontraron una
prueba que evidenciaría la planificación
de los ataques
el documento es como una especie de
eslabón perdido entre una sucesión de
hechos que demuestran que no fueron
casos aislados
antes de la detención la Corte Suprema
había incluido a bolsonaro en la
investigación como posible autor
intelectual este habría incitado
públicamente al fuerte poder de sus
masas de extrema derecha la semana
pasada demostraron tener una capacidad
de convocatoria y de movilización y de
acción violenta sorprendentes quiere
decir esto que todo el lector de
bolsonaro está dispuesto a dar un golpe
de estado o a asaltar y saquear los
principales Palacios públicos no
sin embargo para el analista magnocal
también Habrá más miedo y una mayor
respuesta
había cierta tolerancia hacia los
discursos antidemocráticos pero una vez
que estos discursos se convierten en
acciones la gente Podría tener un poco
más de miedo de hablar o actuar en el
resultado de las elecciones
el 8 de enero miles de personas entraron
en las sedes del poder judicial
ejecutivo y legislativo en Brasilia
provocaron una de las mayores crisis de
las últimas décadas en Brasil desde
entonces ya hay más de 1800 personas
detenidas y siete investigaciones
activas que incluyen políticos y
empresarios